i would like to know how you can say
that they have no ancestral claim to
this land i'd like you to be more
specific which people specifically and
which land specifically i'm talking
about the native americans but there
were many different native americans
need to name all the tribes yes sir and
i'd like you to name it and the reason i
would like you to name all the tribes is
because there were many tribes who
conquered many other tribes just as an
example comanche indians come in and
they conquer areas run by the apache
indians
now the united states comes in and it
owns that land to which tribe should
that revert when the spanish came to
this continent they did create a new
race known as latinos this is a mixture
of spaniards and native american
populations so if we're going to revert
certain land to native populations why
would we not then immediately take that
land away from them because they also
descend from spanish explorers i think
it's a madness of the modern left and it
leads to crazy policy proposals